great news arm is coming to compute
engine stick around if you're looking to
save costs or get up to speed with new
architectures because in this video
we'll give you all the details about the
new t2a machine types that use the new
cpu architectures and are cost-effective
alternatives to traditional x86 servers
the emergence of arm in the data center
represents a shift in the tech industry
that could mean better workloads and
cost efficiencies for you and please
note the company and architecture were
once referred to as arm arm from acorn
risk machines and later advanced risk
machines but today arm arm is no longer
regarded by arm as an acronym until
recently arm chips were mainly
associated with iot and mobile
architectures because of arm's reduced
instruction set and low power
consumption but the evolution of arm has
opened it up to more diverse workloads
including server processors compute
intensive workloads desktops laptops
server machine devices high performance
computing and even some of the fastest
supercomputers in the world
in fact while researching this video i
found out that arm is using the world's
second fastest supercomputer and that
supercomputer held the number one spot
for two years this gives developers more
options to work with because some
workloads can run faster or more
efficiently on arm
also it's part of the end and developer
ecosystem so if your laptop is armed you
can use the same architecture on the
servers
but if you couldn't get access to these
new chipsets before you're out of luck
luckily google cloud is rolling out the
first of its new family of arm vms the
t2a family the t2a vm family represents
gce's initial foray into the arm
ecosystem and uses an ampere ultra
processor the t2a is a cost effective
and powerful offering that enables arm
ecosystem
t2a will support vms with up to 48
physical cores at 3 gigahertz and fixed
vm shapes with 4 gigabytes of memory per
core up to 192 gigabytes so let's take a
deeper look at why you might want to try
it out
switching to the new t2a vms follows the
same process you already used to manage
your google compute engine vms it's easy
to move between arm and x86
architectures for most applications in
fact most web applications written in
java javascript c-sharp python and ruby
don't even need to recompile and most go
programs should work after a recompile
and c plus plus
is c plus plus so personally i have no
idea what will happen if you run your
applications in containers and
orchestrate them using kubernetes you
may want to check out what's new in
google kubernetes engine
gke users will now be able to
incorporate t2a vm node pools into their
clusters you can use arm nodes in gke to
explore how you can develop test and
deploy your containers on the arm
architecture
okay back to gce
please note that this initial offering
has a few limitations for example t2a
vms don't currently offer high cpu or
high mem configs
custom machine types local ssds or gpu
support
but the feature set will change in the
future so be sure to look at the
documentation but if your work profile
matches up with these new arm vms then
you'll see all the benefits we mentioned
previously including high performance
cost efficiency and easy migration
high performance at the right price
point is a critical consideration and
the new t2a series gives you even more
opportunities to use machines that are
best suited for your workload there are
more arm chips rolling out in the future
and features will be added over time so
now is a good time to go and explore
this offering and how can help you save
money if you enjoyed this video be sure
to like and subscribe to stay up to date
with the latest and greatest from the
google cloud tech channel and scroll
down to the description to check out the
quick start guide for more in-depth
information about the new rbms
[Music]
you